YEAH RIGHT. SENATE
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY VETERANS
AFFAIRS WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON- IN
RESPONSE TO COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICE
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS TO THE PUBLIC
TO IN THIS CASE TODAY WILL BE
TO ONE ROOM THE HEARING ROOM
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE. AND
TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING THE
TELECONFERENCE OR VERSUS FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY VIA TELEPHONE
ALSO. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEES
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO
FIVE SIX NINE ZERO NINE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE WILL
MOVE TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU TO A LINE NUMBER.
THIS CAN BE A SHORT AIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU'LL NOW BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
TELEPHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
REMAIN. I WILL MAINTAIN AT A
DECORUM. DURING THE HEARING AS
IT IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING. SERVICE AND OR THE
CONNECTION SHALL BE MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT A HEARING
IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL PATIENT
CHAU ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD WE THANK YOU. BEFORE
WE CONTINUE TODAY'S AGENDA
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. I'D
LIKE TO REMIND MEMBERS TO TURN
ON YOUR MICROPHONE GE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA HERE GROW
EGGMAN MELENDEZ MONDAYS HERE
NEAR MEN. ROTH AMBERG- WE HAVE
A QUORUM THANK YOU- WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ON THE CALENDAR TODAY.
LET'S BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE OH SEVEN AND GOOD
AFTERNOON- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH SEVEN.
THANK YOU VISITORS THANK YOU
SENATORS I'D LIKE TO START BY
STATING THAT ALL TAKE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH ME IN MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL. FIRST TODAY PRESENTS. AB
ONE OH SEVEN WHICH EXPANDS AND
IMPROVES THE TEMPORARY
LICENSURE PROGRAM. FOR SPOUSES
OF ACTIVE DUTY MEMBERS.
MILITARY SPOUSES ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO BE UNEMPLOYED AND
UNDER EMPLOYED WITH MOVING TO A
NEW STATE. AND BURN THROUGH
THEIR SAVINGS AND ARE FORCED TO
CUT CORNERS WHILE THEY WAIT TO
FIND. GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. THEIR MILITARY
SPOUSES. WHO HAVE TO WAIT
MONTHS TO RECEIVE A LICENSE
THAT THEY'RE FULLY QUALIFIED
FOR. MEANWHILE THEY LOSE OUT ON
POTENTIAL INCOME AND ARE UNABLE
TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
AB ONE EIGHTY SIX WAS PASSED IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO CREATE A TAB
FOR. TEMPORARY LICENSURE
PROGRAM. QUICKLY AND EASILY GET
LICENSES IT'S AMANDA TO
RESPONSIBLE BOARDS COMPLETED
THEIR BACKGROUND CHECKS. BUT IT
WAS LIMITED IN THE NUMBER AND
SCOPE OF THE BOARDS OF THE
PROGRAM. THIS IS A BILL WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON FOR YEARS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION NOT WORKING WITH
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION. AND
TRYING TO GET TO SPOUSES
EMPLOYED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- SO THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES- YOU
KNOW THE MILITARY NATIONAL
SECURITY ACTIVITY CALIFORNIA
GENERATED A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE POINT. TWO BILLION WITH A
B. BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. BEGINNING THIS YEAR.
THE MILITARY SERVICES ARE NOW
REQUIRED TO INCLUDE MILITARY
SPOUSE PORTABILITY. AND
EMPLOYMENT AND THEIR MISSION
BASING DECISIONS. FOR THIS BILL
IS VERY TIMELY- AND AGAIN
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
THE AMENDMENTS WORKING WITH OUR
TEAM. AND AT THIS TIME I DO
HAVE. TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT I
HAVE WITH US TODAY TESTIFYING
IS. KELLY MAY DOUGLAS. WHO IS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
THE PACIFIC SOUTHWEST REGIONAL
LIAISON. AND ALSO STEPHEN
MORROW. WHO IS A SERVICE MEMBER
ACTUALLY STATIONED. NEARBY AT
TRAVIS AIR FORCE BASE. MOVE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LATE
THE HEARING. TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIR. MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS
TESTIMONY. EIGHT SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED THREE MINUTES. ALL OF
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS. THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND A POSITION.
ON THE MEASURE SO LET THE WITH
YOUR SUPPORT WITNESS. AND
BELIEVE- AND KELLY MAY DOUGLAS
THAT CORRECT. AND SHE IS WITH-
WITH PACIFIC SOUTHWEST REGIONAL
IS ON DEFENSE STATE LAYS ON
OFFICE. AND WE ALSO HAVE STEVEN
MORAL MILITARY SPOUSE. CHAU WHO
PLAYS BEGAN. THERE ARE TWO
LEADING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KELLY MAY
DOUGLAS AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
POLICY CHANGES PROPOSED WITHIN
AB ONE OH SEVEN. ON BEHALF OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE. A
TOP PRIORITY FOR THE DOCTOR. TO
THE DEPARTMENT IS TO HELP
MILITARY SPOUSES BUT IT'S CLEAR
PORTABILITY. MORE THAN A THIRD
OF MILITARY FATHERS WORK AND
LIFE AND PROFESSION. HOWEVER
STATE THE DIFFICULT TO HIRE MEN
AND PRACTICES FOR RE LICENSURE
OFTEN BURDENSOME. REDUNDANT AND
TIME CONSUMING FOR THEM AND DO
NOT ALLOW FOR THEM TO FIT YOUR
TIMELY EMPLOYMENT UPON.
ARRIVING TO THEIR NEW DUTY
STATION. FOLLOWING MY COME. AND
ECONOMIC ISSUES FROM CAL
SEPARATE HE REDDING ISSUE THAT
TRANSLATE INTO A BROADER
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION ISSUE
CAN UNDERMINE PERSONAL NUMBERS
AND THEREFORE OUR NATION'S
SECURITY THIS IS BECAUSE THERE
IS MEMBERS FREQUENTLY FIGHT
ECONOMIC CONCERNS AT THE TOP
REASON WHY THEY DISCONTINUED
MILITARY SERVICE. NOT VERY
FAMILIES LIKE MOST FAMILIES
ACROSS THE STATE AFTER REQUIRED
TO INCOME TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND
AS A RESULT OF THE STRUCTURAL
ECONOMIC BARRIERS STATE THROUGH
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN MILITARY
THOUGHT THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO
SECURE EMPLOYMENT CALIFORNIA
OTHER SPOUSES ARE STATIONED
HERE. NUMBER COULD BE PUT IN A
DIFFICULT POSITION CHOOSING
BETWEEN THIRTEEN THEIR COUNTRY
OR THE ECONOMIC NEEDS OF THEIR
FAMILY AND DECIDES TO LEAVE
SERVICE. DEPARTMENT IS GRATEFUL
FOR THE INITIATIVE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY I'M
HAPPY TO TURN IT OVER TO EVEN
MORE ON AL GORE THE COMPELLING
PERSONAL STORY TO SHARE
EMPATHIZING THE CHALLENGES
EXPERIENCED BY THE MORE THAN
SIXTY TWO THOUSAND MILITARY AND
PROFESSIONAL IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
DOUGLAS- MISTER. MORROW YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK YOU CAN
GOOD ACTORS SENATOR OUR JULY
MEMBER OF THE CAN. AND THANK
YOU SOME OF THEM SALAS FOR YOUR
ON THIS BILL. I'M A- MARRIAGE
FAMILY. IN MY SPOUSE SHE'S IN
DO AIRFORCE OFFICER I'M
SUPPORTING I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE ZERO SEVEN FOR MULTIPLE
REASONS. I GRADUATED FROM LOMA
LINDA UNIVERSITY WITH MY
MASTERS OF SCIENCE IN MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY THERAPY AN
ACCREDITED SCHOOL LISTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA BBS. AND I COMPLETED
MY COURSE WORK AND ALL CLINICAL
HOURS AND OBLIGATIONS AS
SPECIFIED BY THE CALIFORNIA B.
B. S. STEP ONE BOARDS. LOOK IT
AN EIGHTEEN. SHORTLY AFTER MY
SPOUSE RECEIVED ORDERS TO
RELOCATE FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO WRITE PATTERSON
IN OHIO. REQUIRING ME TO CHANGE
COURSE STOP STUDYING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL EXAMINATION
BEGIN STUDYING FOR THE NATIONAL
LICENSURE PROGRAM. I PASSED
THAT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN. I RECEIVED MY
NATIONAL LICENSE AND BEGAN
PRACTICING AFTER THREE MONTHS
OF JOB SEARCHING AND STUDYING.
NINE MONTHS LATER MY SPOUSE
RECEIVED ORDERS AGAIN TO RETURN
TO CALIFORNIA. YOU TO STATE
LICENSING LAWS AND REQUIREMENTS
OF THE CALIFORNIA BORDER
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES MY NATIONAL
LICENSE WAS NOT VALID OR
ACCEPTED IN CALIFORNIA. I NEED
TO BEGIN STUDYING FOR THE
CLINICAL EXAMINATION. DURING
THE PROCESS TO STUDY
ASSIGNATION ON MY FIRST ATTEMPT
SECURE MY LICENSE AND THEN FIND
AND THEN FIND A POSITION I LOST
A COMBINED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN SALARY DURING THE
EIGHT MONTHS OF NOT WORKING DUE
TO REGULATIONS. MY THE MILITARY
SPOUSE DOES NOT CHOOSE TO
APPROVE THEIR PROFESSIONAL
CAREER EVERY TWO TO FOUR YEARS
BECAUSE IT'S BENEFICIAL JERRY
STACKHOUSE MYSELF CHOOSE TO
APPROVE THEIR CAREER BECAUSE OF
THEIR COMMITMENT TO THEIR
SPOUSE AND MINE TO MY WIFE. AND
OUR SPOUSES COMMITMENT TO OUR
COUNTRY AB ONE OH SEVEN WILL
PREVENT MILITARY SPOUSES FROM
LOSING THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
SALARY LAST TIME AND JOB
SEARCHING AND EASE STRESSFUL
TRANSITIONS FOR FUTURE
PROFESSIONAL THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING. THANK YOU MR MARI
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ROOM- FORTY TWO OH
THREE YEAR AND FOR ANYONE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. I SEE NO
ONE THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELEPHONE. MODERATOR
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
OH SEVEN AND WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN THERE-
NOW. ALMOST ALWAYS LINE NUMBER
TWO SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON LESTER TURN MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
U. THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE COURT TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER TWO SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON A
GERMAN ARTILLERY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JOINING ALL COULD SHARE OF
CALIFORNIANS DEPEND COMMUNITIES
ALLIANCE IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB
ONE OF SEVEN. THANK YOU. NUMBER
TWO SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS KERIS MIGHT WITH THE
NAVY ON BEHALF OF THE ARMY
MARINE CORPS NAVY AIR FORCE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. I'M VERY GRATEFUL THE
AUTHOR FOR INDIGENOUS
COMMONSENSE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND NATIONAL
SECURITY MEASURES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BY NUMBER TWO SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD THIS IS FRAN PEACE
WITH THE BILL MILITARY LIAISON
COUNCIL CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEIR OWN
NOW. THAT'S ONE ZERO. AT THE
TIME OF DAY CARE WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. MODERATOR. PLEASE
ASK ONE MORE TIME. YES SIR IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO SIX ONE ZERO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE OH
SEVEN. WOULD YOU LIKE WE HAVE
SOMEONE ELSE TO IN A MOMENT IF
THE CHAIR. MY NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SANDY PERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE TRAVIS COMMUNITY
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
OF SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR ANYONE AT THE TIME OF
DAY CARE WE HAVE NO NO SIR WE
HAVE NO ENOUGH THANK YOU VERY
GOOD THANK YOU FOR THOSE WHO
CALLED IN SO FORTH NOW LET'S
TURN OVER TO THOSE WHO MAY- BE
IN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM.
I SEE NON. MODERATOR THE TURN
IT OVER TO ANYONE WHO MIGHT BE
IN OPPOSITION AND TODAY I SEE
WE HAVE. A MISS BURNS.
EXECUTIVE OFFICER SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY. AND ALSO-
ROSEANNE HELMS LEGISLATIVE
MANAGER BORDER BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES. SO LET'S BEGIN WITH-
MISS BURNS. YOU MAY BEGIN IN
YOUR OPPOSITION. OF THE SENATE
THE ASSEMBLY BILL. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHARGE A LETTER
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TRACY BURNS AND I'M THE
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY
AND AUDIOLOGY AND HEARING AID
DISPENSERS BOARD. THE BOARD
ADOPTED A PRO THE MOST AMENDED
CONDITION ON AB ONE OH SEVEN
WELL THE BOARD TO COURT FOR
MILITARY VETERANS AND SPOUSES
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THESE
INDIVIDUAL COULD WORK IN
CALIFORNIA FOR TWELVE MONTHS
WITHOUT MEETING THE STATE FLAG
IN QUALIFICATION. FOR PASSING
THE REQUIRED WRITTEN AND
PRACTICAL EXAMINATIONS FOR
HEARING AID DISPENSING THESE
EXAMINATIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
ENSURE MINIMUM COMPETENCY TO
SAFELY PERFORM HEARING TESTS
AND SETTINGS FOR HEARING AIDS
WITHOUT DAMAGING CONSUMERS
YEARS OR HEARING. THE SEEKING
AMENDMENT TO RESTORE LANGUAGE
IN CURRENT LAW THAT MAKE THE
TEMPORARY LICENSE EXPIRE UPON
DENIAL OF AN APPLICATION FOR
PERMANENT LIFE BY THE BOARD.
THIS AMENDMENT WOULD ALLOW THE
BOARD TO LOOKING AT THE STORY
TURBO CONTEMPORARY LIFE IF THE
APPLICANT IS FOUND TO NOT MEET
THE QUALIFICATIONS FOR
LICENSURE IN CALIFORNIA. OR IN
THE CASE OF HEARING EQUIPMENT
THANK THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO PASS
THE REQUIRED EXAMINATIONS
WITHIN THE TWELVE MONTH
TEMPORARY LIFE HISTORY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. OF
OUR REQUEST ONE MOMENT. NOW
YOUR CARD. THANK YOU MISTER I
WILL- IN YOUR OPPOSITE OF AB
ONE OH SO THIS GO TO MISS MISS
HELMS YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR TEST
IN UP. YES THANK YOU SIR- THE
NEW JERSEY AND HEALTH ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES THE BOARD HAS TAKEN AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON AB ONE OH SEVEN ALTHOUGH IT
IS THE BOARD IS GRATEFUL FOR
THE AMENDMENT TO REQUIRE
PASSAGE OF THE LAW AND ETHICS
EXAM. BOARDS STILL HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS REGARDING ISSUANCE OF
A TEMPORARY LICENSE TO
THERAPISTS FROM OTHER STATES
BEFORE THEY HAVE TAKEN THE
REQUIRED CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
COURSEWORK DESIGNED TO PREPARE
THEM TO PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA
THE UNIQUELY DIVERSE
ENVIRONMENT. A GREAT AREA OF
MAJOR CONCERN CITED BY THE
BOARD AS AN EXAMPLE IS THE FACT
THAT SOME OTHER STATES ALLOW
REPAIRED OF THERAPY WITH
CHILDREN WHILE CALIFORNIA
PROHIBITS THAT. NOT BEING AWARE
THAT THIS IS PROHIBITED COULD
CAUSE HARM TO CLIENTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO COMPLETE
THE PRACTITIONER'S LICENSE IN
JEOPARDY IF THEY'RE NOT AWARE
OF THE PROHIBITION. THE BOARD
HAS ALREADY RECENTLY
IMPLEMENTED A STREAMLINED
LICENSURE PROCESS FOR OUT OF
STATE LICENSEES AND ABOUT THAT
IS WORKING WELL TO REDUCE
BARRIERS TO LICENSURE FOR OUT
OF STATE LICENSE APPLICANTS.
COUPLED WITH THE FACT THAT THE
BOARD ALREADY EXPEDITE MILITARY
SPOUSE APPLICATIONS IT BELIEVES
THAT THE BOARD ALREADY HAS A
PROCESS IN PLACE THE BALANCES
EASE OF LICENSURE WITH PUBLIC
PROTECTION. FOR THESE REASONS
THE BOARD CONTINUES TO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TO BE REMOVED FROM ITS
PROVISIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MICHELLE FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION AB ONE OH SEVEN.
ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE HERE. IN OPPOSITION I SEE
NONE NOPE WE'RE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TSTIMONY LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE TELEPHONES. AND MODERATOR
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AB ONE
OH SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PLACE YOU WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ONE OH SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO THEIR OWN NOW. MONTEREY
HIGH. TEMPERATURE WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. ONE Q. THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE ASK ONE MORE TIME. IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
AB ONE OH SEVEN. YES THE CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW IT'S ONE ZERO
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
ONE OH SEVEN. AND AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE CALLED IN THANK
YOU FOR THOSE WHO CALLED IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- NOW
WE'LL- TURN IT BACK OVER TO THE
MEMBERS FOR DISCUSSION. OR
QUESTIONS MEMBERS. CENTER
NUMBER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SO IN MEMBERS SAUCER
BRING THIS ISSUE FORWARD- IS A
MILITARY SPOUSE I CAN CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THIS IN FACT I WAS
THE VICTIM OF IMPLICIT BIAS
BEING A MILITARY SPOUSE FOR
MANY YEARS MY WIFE ALWAYS
HONORING ME ALWAYS HAD BETTER
POSITIONS AND IT WAS SIMPLY
BECAUSE SHE WAS A BETTER LEADER
AND SMARTER THAT'S THE ONLY TWO
REASONS- THIS IS THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE AND- I IF-
YOU AMEND AGAIN I WOULD BE
GRATEFUL IF YOU HAD ME AS A CO
AUTHOR THANK YOU. I'D LOVE TO
HAVE YOU AS A CO AUTHOR THANK
YOU SENATOR. YES AND A SENATOR
MELENDEZ THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN- A
CINNAMON SALAS IT IS GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN I VERY MUCH LIKE
YOUR MASK- I WANTED TO THANK
YOU ALSO FOR BRING THIS BILL
FORTY NAY EVEN WORKING ON THIS
FOR A WHILE. AND YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY ON THIS COMMITTEE IS
A- IS A FORMER MILITARY MEMBERS
SO WE ALL ARE FAMILIAR. WITH
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A PCS MOVE
COMES UP AND A SPOUSE IS KINDA
LEFT WONDERING OKAY NOW WHAT DO
I DO SO NOT ONLY IS IT A- AN
EMOTIONAL BURDEN IT'S A
FINANCIAL BURDEN AS WELL SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR. BEING SO TENACIOUS ABOUT
TRYING TO MOVE THIS- ISSUE
FORWARD I WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR- AND I WOULD- LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT SOME OF THE-
YOU. AND THE CENTER NEWMAN.
THANK YOU BYE TO WOULD- LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL SIMMONS
SHOWERS APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU
DOING HERE. THANK YOU SENATOR
LET ME FORWARD TURN OVER LOOKS
LIKE YOU'VE GOTTEN A LOT OF
SUPPORT BACK TO WOULD LIKE TO
BE ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU
FOR THE SUPPORT AND WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE EACH OF YOU ON AS A CO
AUTHORS PRINCIPLE CLOCKERS. AB
ZERO. THIS MATTER WAS HANDED
OUT TO YOU GUYS EARLIER. AND
THIS LIST OF SHOWS YOU OUT OF
THE FIFTY STATES CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY RANKS TOWARDS THE
BOTTOM. OF ACTUALLY DOING
THINGS FOR MILITARY SPOUSES AB
ONE OH SEVEN. MOVES US IN A
DIRECTION TO CORRECT THAT. YOU
KNOW YOU HEARD THE TESTIMONY
EARLIER- AND JUST TO SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE OPPOSITION
THAT CALLED IN. YOU KNOW WE ARE
WORKING WITH. ALL THE GROUPS
INVOLVED BUT- THIS ALLOWS A
TEMPORARY LICENSURE THEY STILL
HAVE TO PASS. THE EXAM TO
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA. THIS OF
PASSED THE ETHICS EXAM THEY
STILL HAVE TO DO ALL OF THESE
THINGS IS JUST ALLOWS. THE
MILITARY FAMILIES THE ABILITY
TO STILL HAVE INCOME TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES WHILE
THEY'RE DOING THIS. THIS IS
DONE IN ALMOST. AND SOME
VERSION ALMOST ACROSS THE
ENTIRE UNITED STATES LET'S DO
THIS HERE IN CALIFORNIA WANTS
TO WRITE BY OUR MILITARY
FAMILIES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. AND
MOTION PLEASE. A SENATOR
MELENDEZ- IS MADE THE MOTION
AND PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON AND CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ARCHULETA BY I
GROWTH EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AYE NEWMAN
ALL RIGHT HUMAN AYE ROTH AMBERG.
NUMBER I. IT OPENS. THE BILL IS
OUT FIVE ZERO. WILL MOVE WITH-
AND IT'S FIVE ZERO- WE'RE
EXPECTING A COUPLE MORE AND
WILL COME BACK LATER LET'S GO
ON NOW TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. NOW MOVE ON TO A JURY-
AJ ARE CAN. AND- FOR THE TO
CLEAN UP THE MICROPHONE THERE
BEFORE WE START. AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI WELCOME YOU
MAY PROCEED WITH AJ ARE TEN.
THANK AS SENATOR OR CHAIR MAN
AND- ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ALREADY ACCEPTING. SURE SAW
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- TO ADD TO
REPUBLIC GO ABOVE VIETNAM
VETERANS WHO SERVED IN THE
VIETNAM WAR IN MY A RESOLUTION.
I HAVE ALSO TAKEN TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS SO TWO REMOVAL
SENATOR DAVID THE MAN AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHORS THAT THE
US SENATORS SO REQUEST. BUT IT
DOES SENATORS SO TOM NUMBER
Gí
A COAL OR FOSSIL UPON THEIR
REQUEST. I PERSONALLY UP WOULD
LIKE TO THANK. RONNIE KARA
ROGER AND ASSEMBLY WITH TIA
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
TIRELESSLY WITH ME AND MY STAFF
WILL. THIS IS A PASSED A COUPLE
OF WEEKS- TOOL ENSURE THE
LANGUAGE OF BEST SERVE SERVE
THE INTERESTS OF ALL OF OUR
BRAVE VETERANS. I'M PRETTY
STOKED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
JOINT DON'T RESOLUTION TEN. ON
IMPORTANT TO STEP UP TO WORD%
DOC RECOGNIZING THE-
CONTRIBUTIONS TO KOREAN AND
VIETNAMESE SO SOLDIERS MADE IN
THE VIETNAM WAR. A. J. L. TEN
URGES THE PRESIDENT AND THE
CONGRESO TO PERMIT STATES TO
EXTEND THE BURIAL AND A MEMORY
ON THE BENEFITS ARE IN STATE
VETERANS OF CEMETERIES SO. TWO
REPUBLICAN OLD CARILLO VETERANS
AND THE REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM
VETERANS WHO SERVED IN THE
VIETNAM WAR AND- WHO
SUBSEQUENTLY BECAME A UNITED
STATES A CITIZENS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU R. TO JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING THIS IMPORTANT
PROJECT THE RESOLUTION TO HONOR
OUR BRAVES KOREAN AND THE
VIETNAMESE OF SOLDIERS SO WHO
FOUGHT ALONGSIDE THE UNITED
STATES. WITH ME TODAY ARE
CALLING IN TO TOUCH UPON TO
TESTIFY IS SUPPORTABLE AGL TEN
IS SO OFTEN SHOWN WITH THE
KOREAN VETERANS OF THE VIETNAM
WAR AND- SOUTH READ A BOOK WITH
THE AMERICAN LEGION IT FOR THEY
HAVE WAITED THIS LONG WHETHER
THEY ARE SO I HOPE WITH THE ARE
STILL WAITING. AND I'M ARE AT
THE CONCLUSION OF ONTARIO'S
TESTIMONY WE HAVE A SEVERAL
KOREAN VETERANS SO WAITING
SINCE ABOUT TEN O'CLOCK GOT TO
TESTIFY. IDEAS SUPPORT THE- IN
COUTURE A TWO LETTER SENATORS
AND THE COMMITTEES. WILL IS MY
YA STAY PALM WE- WHO WELL INTO
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF
MEMBERS SO SEOUL MARCH NASA. A
COUPLE WEEKS FOR PRINTING THIS-
RESOLUTION ALL FOR
RECONSIDERATION I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE GOOD THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE WILL NOW- GOING ON TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT MODERATOR
PLEASE RELEASE LINE. LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS TODAY WE'VE
ALFORD TRONG REPRESENTING
KOREAN VETERANS OF VIETNAM WAR
AND SHE'D READ BUT OF ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN LEGION SO WE'LL
BEGIN WITH MISTER CHUNG YOU
HAVE. THE FLOOR PLEASE PROCEED.
A GOOD USE THE SHOW AND SAID.
MY NAME IS OUR CHIU. I YOU IN
THE RAIN L. THREE CAB. I YOU
GROUP THESE. COULD COMMITTEE S.
COME VETERANS AMERICA. I'M
CREEKS MY TO STOP. AS TIM. HOW
FOR CAREER ON THE MAY. VETERANS
VIETNAM WAR. ALSO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY. GRAHAM
STEVEN CHOI CHU COOLEY INTO
REFUSAL. EIGHT ZERO TEN- MY
SOMEBODY. ASIA TEN MOVED OVER
TO THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES TO PERMIT. ALL STATE TO
CREEKS TEND ABILITY UNDER
MEMORIAL BENEFIT YOU STATE THE
BEDROOMS SEVEN PRODUCE COOLEY
POVERTY CARILLO BETTER LIVES-
SORRY AND BATTLEWORLD. AND ALL
QUICKLY BECAME. UNITED STATES
CITIZENS. THE MINNESOTA BE TO-
OR SO- URGENTLY STATE CONGRESS
AND KRISTA MOGILA STATES.
PLEASE STAND PERCENT BENEFIT IN
THIS ON SOME. BACKGROUND.
EIGHTEEN TO FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
EXPANDER ARE BENEFIT. INITIAL
ON VETERANS CENTER. TO- SO
LET'S WHO SAW IN AMERICA THANK
YOU CAMERA UNIT YOU DON'T IN
THE BATH WAR. AND THE WHO
SUBSEQUENT. BECAME WHICH
PROVIDES UNITED STATES. AT THE
TO DELAY STATES THE REPUBLIC
PROVIDE THE MORE MEAT SO CALLED
THE UNITED STATES STILL BETTER
WAR. BE OLDER HELLO. CLOCKS TO
THEM TWENTY ARE YOU COULD ALSO
JUST SORT OF THE IN THE AND I'M
IT COULD NOT TWO SIX FIVE AND
THE 97 DEGREES YOU PROBABLY
FORCE SO. WELL ONE TWO THOUSAND
NINE ON FIFTY TO USE AND FIVE
NINE KILLED IN ACTION DURING
THE WAR APPROACH MONEY THE SAME
RATE PRO KEPT IS UNITED BEFORE.
HOW WE HAVE HE IS FIGHTING FOR
FIVE ALONE SIDE THE UNITED ONLY
STEALING OF GET A LITTLE
CLEARER MADE YET WILL BE AS
WELL NOT CLOSE TO THREE. AND
REASONABLE TO HOTEL BED IN
STATE OR NATIONAL VETERANS
CEMETERY. HELLO PUSHER AS CAN
CROSS THE CLINTON CARILLO
VETERANS. HOW OF YOUR STATES DO
YOU NOTING. AND WOULD DO YOU
RISK INCREASED HONORABLY IN
STATES TO GOOD THIS BETTER TO
WRITE BURIAL MEMORIAL BENEFIT
INSTEAD AND THE SOME OUTSIDE.
THREE IS YOUR TURN IS PASSED IT
WILL BE. TERRIBLE POSITIVELY
IMPACT ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AN INMATE ON AND
OUT OF RESPECT IF YOU A CLOSE
UP WE HAVE A TESTIMONY YET TO
HEAR. OKAY WORDWIDE AMERICAN
BBQS AGREE ON THE NECESSITY ON
CONCRETE PIERS OKAY- ALL
DISMISSED WHO ARE LIKELY TO SEE
A GREAT POTENTIAL PRAISE FROM
THE KOREA GOVERNMENT END THE
REDUCE TRANSIT POLITICAL
GRAYSON IT COULD BE ALSO SEND.
GROW MESSAGE THAT THE UNITED
STATES- TO TAKE CARE OF THE
BILL- FIVE OVERALL THEM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
JOHN FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN. A
J. R. TEN AND NOW WILL MOVE ON
TO MISTER. REED AND YOUR
TESTIMONY SIR. THANK YOU SO
THAT AFTERNOON. AFTER CHAIRMAN
MANY BUT GOVERNMENT RELATES
THANK YOU YOU TO EVERYONE OF
THE YOUR SERVICE OUR- I'M-
AMERICAN LEGION OF VETERAN
AFFAIRS NINE WITH REGARD
RELATIONS I WOULD LIKE TO READ
A STATEMENT. FROM BATHROOM IS A
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN LEGION
AND SERVED ALONGSIDE. THE
REPUBLIC OF CREATURE. PLEASE
PROPOSED I DO SURE DO FELT.
INSTITUTE BUT THE REPUBLIC
KOREA BUT SHALL NOT TO BE SOME
OF THE MOST. I SOLDIERS I EVER
SEE. THAT HURDLE SIDE S. TROOP
HAVE FOR IN OUR- THERE IS A
PLACE I REMEMBER IT AND QUOTE.
GEN APARTMENT CALIFORNIA ISN'T
SUPPORT OF AJ K. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- THANK YOU MISTER. FOR
YOUR PRESENT- NOW MOVE ON TO
THE WITH THAT BE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY- THREE AND YOUR WELL TO
COME TO THE MIKE. AND PLEASE
STATE YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AND I BELIEVE- ALL
YOU NEED IS YOUR NAME. AND YOUR
UNIT AND- YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. HI
MY NAME IS PUNK. ROCK NINETY
CLYDE K. A. JUNE. FOURTH TWENTY
EIGHT WHY DO WE AND- MY
APOLOGIES OF QUALITY ON THAT
PRESIDENT. ALL YOU WORKABLE ONE
IN CALL. BUT I FIVE IN THE NICE
TO. NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE I WAS
FIGHTING IN BED NOT. TO YOUR-
CHAU I'M LEAVING HERE VERY
IMPORTANT. I HAVE FIVE UNITED
STATES CHAU WE BELIEVE WE ARE
FOREVER. PREVIOUS SUPPORT. J.
OPERATE ON. HA OURS CAN
FREEZEPROOF THE ENTRY OR NOT
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND WELCOME
HOME ANYONE ELSE. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. OKAY WELL THANK YOU
THAT THAT COMPLETES OUR
TESTIMONY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE- NOW WITH TURNER
WITNESSES VIA TELEPHONE THAT
WILL BE CALLING IN ON A JURY
PART TEN MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT OF A AJ ARE TEN AND WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AJ ARE TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A AJ ARE
TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE. IN THEIR
OWN NOW. FORMER MINISTER WE HAD
PEOPLE DOING OUT NOW THANK YOU.
GATHER LINE NUMBER WAS THAT
WOULD LINE NUMBER TWO SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE HELLO. I TRIED.
I SUPPORT BECAUSE. THANK YOU
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IN THIS CONVERSATION
ABOUT SADDAM- YOUR CLEAR
MERICAN VIETNAM VETERAN AND I
AM SUPPORT INTRODUCTION THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER TWO NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GABRIELLE I CAN AND I HE
ARE STRICTLY SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AJ ARE TEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BY NUMBER TWO
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JANICE SONG I LOOK FORWARD AJ I
CAN. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO
NINETY ONE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF A COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MARGARET CHAN AND I'M THE
DAUGHTER OF A PROUD U. S.
CITIZEN AND YET NOT MORE
DEADLINE AND I'M IN THE COURT
OF H. A. R. K. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
MODERATOR WOULD YOU ASK ONE
MORE TIME IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
Q. IN SUPPORT OF AJ ARE. TEN
THANKYOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A AJ ARE
TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT'S ONE ZERO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF A AJ ARE TEN. THANK
YOU AND WE DO HAVE A FEW MORE
PEOPLE SHOWING UP ONE MOMENT.
RUN AHEAD. MY NUMBER TWO NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KAREN
CHAIN AND I AM IN SUPPORT THIS
AJ ARCHITECT. THANK YOU. A LOT
MY NUMBER TWO EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MINUS THE ALSO. ISOKO
OCCUR A VERY. HANDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. JULY NUMBER EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI HELLO HI THANK YOU MY
NAME IS STRONG LEADING. I
SUPPORT THE AGENCY ARE TEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE LINE
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS DICK CHENEY ON
LIFE SUPPORT AG ALL TEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LIE NUMBER TWO
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER TWO
NINETY FIVE MAYBE YOU'RE ON
MUTE. MY NUMBER TWO NINE EIGHT
FIVE NINE- MY NAME IS JANICE
SONG I SUPPORT THE H. A R. TEN.
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME OF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
COULD YOU. MODERATOR WOULD YOU
ASK ONE MORE TIME IF ANYONE
ELSE IS IN SUPPORT OF A J. R.
TEN. YES SIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A AJ ARE TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE
ZERO BECAUSE THE POOR OF A J.
R. TEN. AND AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE Q. THANK
YOU HAVING HEARD FROM
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW MOVE INTO
THE- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AJ ARE CAN. ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM. I SEE NO ONE. OUR
MODERATOR. ANYONE VIA TELEPHONE
IN OPPOSITION TO AJ ARE TEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AJ ARE
TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
IT BACK INTO Q. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AJ ARE TEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
THEIR OWN NOW. AT THIS TIME IF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE TO. A
MODERATOR WOULD YOU ASK ONE
MORE TIME IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION JJ ARE TEN. YES THE
CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF A J. R. TEN COULD
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT'S ONE
ZERO TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AJ ARE. TEN AND AT THIS TIME IF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWING Q.
AND YOUR MODERATOR NOW WILL
BRING IT BACK TO SENATORS
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATORS- CENTER ON BIRD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI-
LAST HEARING THERE WAS SOME
DISQUIETED CONCERNING
AMENDMENTS THAT I PROPOSED.
WITHOUT GIVING YOU NOTICE I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT- I THEY
SHOULD HAVE GIVEN YOU SOME
NOTICE BEFORE- ASKING ABOUT
THOSE AMENDMENTS IN COMMITTEE.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
YOUR FLEXIBILITY INCLUDING THE
VIETNAM VETERAN SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT THAT'S POINT ONE.
POINT TWO IS I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE IT APPEARS THAT WE
HAVE QUITE A NUMBER OF. A
VETERANS- FROM THE REPUBLIC OF
KOREA. A MILITARY WHO FOUGHT IN
VIETNAM YEARS SERVICE IN YOUR
VALOR- ARE LEGENDARY AND REMAIN
LEGENDARY- I KNOW THAT CAPTAIN
NEWMAN I SERVED IN KOREA. NOT
AT THE SAME TIME BUT- WITH WITH
THE KOREAN SOLDIERS I WAS
SECONDED FOR DIVISION AND- IN
KIND OF THE NUMBER OF VETERANS
WHO FOUGHT IN VIETNAM AND- THE-
HONOR OF. BEARING OF THOSE WHO
FOUGHT WITH US IN VIETNAM IT IS
ALL OURS SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR BURKE CENTER NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MR CHAU RUG I GUIDE.
MISTER TRY WHAT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BACK I'M
GLAD TO SEE THAT WE COULD GET A
POSITIVE RESOLUTIONS MATTER I'M
GLAD TO SEE THEY'RE GOING TO
PASS THIS RESOLUTION TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE. ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE- TO CENTER ON BRIDGE
COMMENTS I TOO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE. THE VETERANS OF THE
REPUBLICAN CAREER ARMY TO HERE
TODAY AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SAY YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE COMES
ON THE DOT. THANK YOU. AND
SENATOR MELENDEZ. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN- A
CINNAMON CHOI. IT GIVES ME
GREAT PLEASURE TO WELCOME YOU
TO THIS COMMITTEE TODAY AND
ALSO TO SHOW YOU- THE
RESPECTING DIFFERENCE THAT YOU
SAID DESERVE FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD. NAY HAVE
NUMBER PEOPLE BEHIND YOU WHO I
SPOKE WITH IN THE HALLWAY. WHO
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THEM FOR THEIR
SERVICE IN EIGHTEEN THE UNITED
STATES DURING THE VIETNAM
CONFLICT- I- NEAR THIS IS A
RESOLUTION THAT GOES FOR TO
CONGRESS ULTIMATELY THEY WILL
DECIDE. IT IS OUR TASK TO-
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEND THAT REQUEST
TO THEM WHICH I BELIEVE WE HAVE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON- SO
WITH THAT- I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
YOUR RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THERE'S NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENT. I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND- ALSO THANK YOUR
GUEST. OF THE VETERANS WHO
SERVED. ALONGSIDE OUR MILITARY.
AND WE THANK YOU WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE WELCOME HOME.
IS I'M SERVED IN THE VIETNAM
ERA. ALWAYS RUN INTO SOMEONE
WHO SERVED IN THE VIETNAM ERA
AND I ALWAYS SAY. WELCOME HOME.
AND WE THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING US BACK
TOGETHER. AND WE CAN CLEAR THE
AIR TO SHOW THAT WE SUPPORT OUR
VETERANS WE SUPPORT THE MEN AND
WOMEN IN UNIFORM. ACROSS THIS
NATION AND THOSE WHO HAVE GIVEN
THEIR LIVES AND THEN SACRIFICE
SO MUCH. AND TO THOSE WHO ARE
THERE IN THE AUDIENCE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR SACRIFICE
AND FIGHTING SIDE BY SIDE WITH
OUR MILITARY. AND NOW THAT WE
ADDED THE SOUTH VIETNAMESE
SOLDIERS- TO THAT. WE ALSO
THANK THEM AS WELL. AND CENTER
OBERG I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REMARKS- BECAUSE IT WAS SO
IMPORTANT. TO AGAIN AS I SAID
CLEAR THE AIR WE THANK YOU FOR
THAT. SO WITH THAT. I TOO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ADDED. TO THE BILL
AS A CO. AND NOW I ALLOW YOU TO
GO AHEAD AND CLOSE. THANK YOU A
SENATOR ARCHULETA. OF FOR
ALLOWING ME TO. BRING IT BACK
ON YOU ARE VERY CONSIDERATION
OF PERMITS TO WAS A VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATED AND THE OLD
ALTHOUGH COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO
YOUR SUPPORT AND ALL- SENATOR
NUMBER OAK SO. A COMMENDATION
TO ED TO- VIETNAM VIETNAMESE SO
SOLDIERS ARE IN MY RESOLUTION-
SENATOR. JAN AT THE- USED TO BE
SENATOR NON WITH SOMEBODY
MEMBERS JANET YOU'RE AND- SHE
HAD THE SEPARATE. RESOLUTION
SUGGESTED DABABNEH A SINCE IT
WAS SAW ALL. FORTY EIGHT OF FOR
SOME TIME AND A SHE WAS SO
HAPPY THAT THE TO UPSET MY
PROPOSAL. TO INCLUDE DAHLE
VIETNAMESE SO SOLDIERS ARE IN
MY RESOLUTION AND THERE SHE
BECAME THE JOINT AUTHORS AND
THEN OUR BE HAPPILY THAT DAHLE
ALL ALL OF YOU WERE A SENATOR
NEWMAN THE SO AND THEN ALSO A
CHAIRMAN NOT TO LET US IN
MAINE- AND ON ONLY BE OPEN TO
ANY ADULT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT SUPPORTS
US- YES I HAVE- INDICATED-
THIS. BILL HAS BEEN. ARE YOU
ARE YOU EXPECTED TO. READ PHONE
YEAH QUIET THING DOES ABOUT THE
DECEMBER KANNST. ON A PARTS.
BROUGHT ABOUT ISSUE TODAY MANY
SUPPORT US ON AN THEN ALSO
VIETNAM. SOLDIERS SO ARM FROM
SUCH. READ HORRIBLE THOUGHT
AND- PATIENTLY WAITING SINCE
ABOUT TEN O'CLOCK I THINK
THAT'S A MOMENT IDEA EVEN
EARLY- WAITING FOR THIS MOMENT.
THOUGH- WITH YOUR- SUPPORT AND
THE PASSING OF THIS A G. R. TEN
WOULD MEAN SO MUCH TO THEM I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL I BOUGHT.
THIS THANK YOU SO MUCH INTO THE
VETERANS ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR. YOUR PATIENCE NOW MOTION
PLEASE. A CENTER JOSH- YOUR
MOTION AND CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. H. A R. TEN THE
MOTION AS BE ADOPTED AS AMENDED
ARCHULETA ARE WHAT I'D GROVE
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE MELENDEZ AYE
MELENDEZ AYE NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE
ROTH NUMBER RIGHT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OKAY THEN THE VOTE
COUNT AGAIN WAS. FIVE ZERO FIVE
ZERO. THE BILL ITSELF OKAY
THANK YOU AND NOW CONTINUE MY
CLOTHES. AND ONCE AGAIN
EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WAS JUST INFORMED
ROTH WILL NOT BE RETURNING WE
CAN CLOSE THE ROLES ON ONE OH
SEVEN AS WELL AND BLADES IN
GENERAL I'M LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME YOUR EFFORT-
BEING HERE WITH US TODAY. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO- SO- LET EVERYONE
KNOW HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY BOTH VIA
TELEPHONE AND IN PERSON. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF
FOR PUTTING THIS MEETING
TOGETHER AND- THOSE WHO CALLED
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE ON
MILITARY VETERANS AFFAIRS OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT YOU
TO A. B. INCLUDED- IN YOUR
TESTIMONY ON THE OFFICIAL
RECORDS AND- WE THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN. FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND WE
WILL NOW CONCLUDE THIS AGENDA.
IN THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
MILITARY VETERANS AFFAIRS- IS
HEREBY ADJOURNED THANK YOU. SO
WE WERE ABLE.